corporate america continues to get woker
by the day
you know we've covered a few of these
bizarre commercials where it's all
just about some leftist political
message you don't even know what the
product is until the end
i've tried to guess what the commercials
are actually
selling other than leftist politics so
one viewer named er
suggested that we go through this one
i'm going to try i've now got a lot of
practice with these commercials so i'm
going to try to be able to guess
the product before the end of the
commercial let's roll it
there once was a man who fell in love
with his own reflection
all day he started to approve
starving others of his attention
as the weeks moved he was glued
some thought he'd eat himself like food
so this is selling like barack obama's
next book or something it seems like a
pretty app description
until self-worship
turned him into a gift
[Music]
a gift not just for him to treasure
[Music]
but a gift that brought the whole world
pleasure
and so i put this question to you all
does that not make self-obsession
the most selfish act of all
what
[Music]
this is so creepy
[Music]
make yourself a gift to the world
equinox gym that was a gym
you know what's so amazing about that as
i thought there was going to be this
really profound point
about you know narcissism and or
self-obsession as a culture why that's
bad you know i thought they'd kind of
cast right-wingers or something as
self-obsessed even though
it would seem the left checks that box a
little more these days
but then it became an out-and-out
defense
of narcissism that was the
the commercial was actually like yes
narcissism is good
only love yourself loving yourself is
good not
the sin have pride in who you are
be you know only only be focused on
yourself and no one else
which is also the sin that caused the uh
the bringer of light not joe biden but
lucifer satan to fall like lightning
from heaven
okay well that's our culture is so now
completely lost that one side can look
at a commercial and
see them describing like the worst thing
they could be describing
that traditionally in the west has been
viewed as the worst thing that could be
described and the left say hey isn't
that good join our gym
that's equinox
[Music]
you